[Music]
[Applause]
he's former NFL quarterback led the
Seahawks to uh the NFC championship and
went to a Super Bowl former ESPN analyst
Matt Hasselbeck on the program how's
life there Matt you doing
okay I'm doing great it's a little
different I uh been coaching High School
football having a blast our season just
ended last Wednesday and uh it's a lot
of work but uh it's very rewarding
and um you know I'm really sort of
thankful for the opportunity this year
okay if people are watching on peacock
they can see all the footballs back
there all the helmets back there what's
the one thing that you go that's my
prized possession of everything I have
there man none of it you know like I
grew up my dad play my my dad played in
the NFL and like he'd get these game
balls you know he played nine years for
four teams and like me and my brothers
we would just like scuff those game
balls up like it'd be like oh Orange
Bowl Colorado versus Ohio State it'd be
like this was given to you by Bill
Parcels you know blah blah blah and then
we just that's what we played with man
like like I have the Marshon I I guess I
I didn't know this at the time I had the
Marshon Lynch beastquake ball you know
from that big wild card game it was in
my daughter's room for a while like that
dog was probably chewed on by my dog you
know what mean so like sort of none of
it I don't know what else to do with it
it's uh I don't know it's just stuff
it's the memories I think that matter
more to me okay should a team with a
losing record be able to host a playoff
game well I'm super biased because we
were seven and N in Seattle in 2010 when
uh Pete Caroll was first year head coach
we had a tough year and then for
whatever reason the defending world
champion New Orleans Saints Drew Brees
Shawn pyton um they were the wild card
team and had to come play us at seven
and n and we won the game you know so
but but I I tell people a lot you know a
lot about about this and I was talking
to my high school team about this this
year Pete Caroll had us believe in that
we were not seven and nine like they all
everyone in the NFL says hey you got
gotta play your best football at the end
of the year Pete Carol had us believing
that we are zero and zero they are zero
and zero we deserve to be here and I
think that was a big reason that you
know we played so well that day and we
and we beat him so uh no it doesn't make
sense but like playoff football and NFL
football doesn't make sense sometimes
and I'm always told well Rah ra does
doesn't work in the NFL a college guy
doesn't work in the NFL why is Pete
Carroll a raah ra guy the oldest coach
in the NFL even though he doesn't act it
how does that work Len I was 35 years
old when I was his starting quarterback
and the last thing I wanted was this
like Rah ra college guy like I I was
just not gonna be into it bag drills you
got to tap like the the top of the door
before you walk into every room before
you go out to practice like I wanted to
hate it I literally wanted to hate it
and listen back then 35 years old as a
starting quarterback was like ancient
you know Tom Brady and people have like
blown that out of the water but back
then you know so like all I can say is I
thought he was incredible as a head
coach like he had like a John Wooden
quality about him where like on
Wednesdays our coaches our assistant
coaches we weren't even allowed to talk
about who we were playing next it was
just about us versus us our best versus
our best our ones versus our ones which
is very different in the NFL so I didn't
necessarily think it was uh it was as
raw raw as it was we're gonna do
everything right and the score will take
care of itself which for me is a Bill
Walsh thing that I learned from Mike
holgren and Andy Reid and I believed in
that and and so you know I'm I'm a huge
fan of Pete I think he does a great job
as we like to do we look at you know the
Bills or the cowboy if you're looking at
a game do we look and praise the bills
for what they did or we you know spend
that time criticizing the Cowboys and I
I don't know X's and O's at at at a
level to discuss this but I only taking
what I saw and that's buffalo's defense
two high safeties seem to frustrate or
confuse Dak
Prescott can you explain what they were
doing that made him seem really
pedestrian I'll make it even simpler
than that you know when you travel the
country you meet NFL fans okay there are
very few fans that are as great as the
Buffalo Bill fans right they're just
they're special that way I mean there
there are other fan bases that are great
but mostly what you hear from Buffalo
Bills fans is like they'll tell you the
story when they went saw Bill's game
okay and I would just say the same thing
throw kind of the x's and know out a
little bit you talk to NFL quarterbacks
where do you hate to play on the list on
the podium is I hate to play in Buffalo
in December and that was before they had
Josh Allen so I just think that when you
go on the road there's a crazy crown on
that field it kind of throws people off
a little bit the weather the wind uh
they play this stupid Horn uh not when
you're at the line of scrimmage but when
you're in the Huddle trying to call a
play so if you have a play that's called
29 techs and there's another play that's
called 28 TS and you're expecting your
you know I'm from Boston and my left
tackle is from Alabama and you're
expecting him to hear it perfectly just
the communications at the line of
scrimmage in the Huddle like anyone
who's played in Buffalo you're just like
yeah I get it it like they look like a
high school team that hasn't practiced
but it's hard to go on the road that's
why this HomeField Advantage thing
matters so much and it matters more for
some than it does for others and think
about think back to like when I was
growing up the bills were going to four
consecutive Super Bowls a big big part
of that was how hard it was for the
Raiders for the Dolphins for certain
people to go up there and play in bu
Buffalo it's a real thing but do you
think Buffalo had that game plan they
were going to run the ball 40 times
against
Dallas who who like who are you Buffalo
doesn't run the ball like that they they
really don't no but what happens when
you're a playall caller if something
works you keep doing it until the other
team proves they have an answer for it
it happens in Blitz like I remember one
time we were playing the Philadelphia
Eagles an early start for me they
brought this like Brian Dawkins and
another linebacker Blitz four times a
game like that was all they were ever
going to bring it so like we weren't
going to worry about it too much well
guess what we never picked it up in
those four times so guess what it was
blood in the water we saw it probably 14
times but we had no answer and so like I
think that's a little bit what happened
last night yeah I'm still trying to
figure out the Dolphins and the
Cowboys and maybe a little bit with the
Eagles like tonight I wouldn't be
surprised if they lost this game um the
ners it feels like we know who they are
how many teams do you think you go I
know exactly who that team is whether
they're on the road or they're at home
well there's some teams that you feel
really confident in you know when the
49ers are healthy when Brock P's healthy
I think you feel really confident in
that team but it's also the NFL I mean
it's also the NFL that like anybody can
win there's a reason they say Any Given
Sunday they don't say any given Saturday
they don't say any given Friday night
this is the NFL and you know you come
into a a game plan with what you think
is going to work or you know these guys
are human like how many times have you
seen the best team in football lose to a
team that's never won it's just I
remember when I was playing the Detroit
Lions where they went 0 and 16 that year
that one year and like no one wanted to
be the team that lost to the Lions but
like every single one of us could have
been that team like they weren't that
bad they really weren't but it's just uh
you know I think that's part of what's
great about the about the NFL anybody
can beat anybody talking to Matt
Hasselbeck former NFL quarterback and
former member of uh ESPN you know you
start to look at MVP candidates
and I don't know what your criteria is
on what is most valuable I I've said all
along that I don't know if a team ask
their quarterback to do more for them
than Baltimore does with Lamar Jackson
um but you know that doesn't mean Brock
pie shouldn't or can't win or if it's
Tyreek Hill or whoever else we're
throwing in there but uh how do you
decide who is an
MVP what is the criteria like who knows
it's not the Heisman I know that you
know that that's not what it is um
there's going to be guys like that
deserve it and I think as the season
comes to an end like it'll kind of
clarify itself a little bit Lamar
Jackson certainly one of those guys um
the vote could get split in San Fran
with perie and mcaffrey I'll just say
this back in 05 Sean Alexander won the
MVP Mike hren was our head coach uh
Brett favid won three consecutive MVPs
uh when I was in Green Bay Mike holgren
was the coach and hearing what Mike
holgren would say to our team
and I particularly remember this with
Shawn Alexander he was like we are going
to go for this award we are going to get
Shawn this award we're GNA get him the
NFL touchdown record Sean you're going
to do it but you're not going to do it
alone you're going to do it with our
fullback ma strong with our offensive
line Walter Jones and Steve Hutchinson
this is a team award okay the MVP is a
team award this is a feather in the cap
we had two wide receivers that year from
Penn State Joe J vicious and Bobby
Ingram who knew how to BL in the running
game and he challenged the wide
receivers you right here you might be
the difference in Shawn Alexander
getting this award so I don't know who
who who Who's Who should get the award I
don't know but I do think I do know this
there are coaches and players in the NFL
who if their teammate gets it they view
it as like we got it and so they're
they're all chasing a Lombardi they want
to hoist a Lombardi but the MVP is is a
cool thing obviously for the guy who
gets it but but for the teammate as well
and we felt that with Shawn when he
earned it and um it was just a really
really cool
thing what were you like when you're
watching Favre do what he's doing and
trying to understand how to play
quarterback in the NFL because I don't
think anything he does is applicable to
what you did when you were a
starter yes and no like Brett you know
Brett you see the wild stuff but I I'll
say this my very first quarterback
meeting that I ever had was with Andy
Reid he was our quarterback's coach in
Green Bay and he said listen Brett Favre
is amazing okay but his decision making
his fundamentals you know those types of
things they're terrible so don't study
that do not study that what I want you
to study is all the other stuff the
intangibles how he leads the Huddle how
he leads the team how he knows the name
of everybody in the building how he
intimidates the opponent without even
saying one word and so it was those
types of things the the other thing that
I noticed about him is like in college
for me I played a little bit like a
robot all right if they're in an underf
front they bring two backers here I
throw the hot to the running back Brett
was like man screw that I don't freaking
care the Z receivers open Robert Brooks
is open Antonio Freeman's open Mark
chimura is open I don't care and so and
and I would hear Mike hren say this he'd
say Brett you're an artist not a
blacksmith you're a artist not a
mathematician and so he just played ball
like you played at recess when you had a
snow day and you were just out in the
front yard of the street with your
friends and so like that I think is what
I took from him yes it's important to
play on time you know I was I was
looking the fun at the fundamentals of
the backup quarterback Doug Peterson but
I was watching sort of like the Reckless
abandoned fun that Brett Favre played
with and there's a fine line and it it
took me like three years to figure it
out but it was cool it was definitely
cool Sterling sharp notd in the Hall of
Fame what are we missing
here well the Hall of fame's an imper
perfect science there's a lot of
lobbying as you know it's uh it's a
little political it's a lot of timing
I'll just know this when I got to Green
Bay Sterling sharp was not there but the
way that Brett Favre coached every
receiver at all times the the sentence
would usually start something like this
well this is what Sterling would used to
do or this is what Sterling told me so
his impact there was felt for many years
after yeah he was dominating man and
like Terell Davis got in injury cut
short his career and I don't know why we
we don't apply that with with Sterling
maybe uh and like how many years do you
need to play at a high level before you
go you know that's Hall of Fame worthy
in today's game you know Gail SARS got
in he got injured you know with his knee
never came back but trell Davis that's
not that long ago what when I was
playing the the thing it was said in
locker rooms I don't know if it was true
was six Pro bowls six Pro bowls get get
you to K but uh but Pro Bowls have
changed you know guys bail out you know
you're you're going to the Pro Bowl but
you're not voted to the Pro Bowl it's a
it's a very now there is no Pro Bowl you
know so like it's it's a different thing
but I think Terell Davis and in uh and
Alex Gibbs and you know John like they
they kind of brought that zone scheme
and sort of changed the game and if you
look at the Run game that you see in the
NFL right now um like if you had to
point to a if I had to point to a point
where it's just like oh it really
started to change here with that Mike
Shanahan offense that now you see you
know everybody running um you know
Terrell Davis had a huge part of that
it's great to talk to you and hope
you're enjoying the high school stuff
seems like uh a lot of fun if they
listen to you who are you channeling
here what what former coach are you are
it's a it's a lot of Mike hren it's a
lot of Jim zor actually it's uh it's a
little bit of Pete Caroll um I was
coaching my son though who was the
senior quarterback so it was a lot of
Mike holgren and me a little bit of
clashing at times but uh we we won the
state championship this year so it was a
great it was like uh at Gillette it's
the first time that I've ever won a game
at Gillette so it felt it felt pretty
good uh great to talk to you and uh
thanks again for joining us anytime
that's Matt Hasselbeck former NFL
quarterback led the Seahawks to the
Super Bowl in' 05 and work for the
Mother Ship as well